where can people find out more about you
and what's next for you
well uh they can find out i have a i
have a website
at
drmik11.org
we have a center website which is
allencenter.tufts.edu
i have a twitter feed which is at
drmik11
and uh what's next uh it's a good
question i
i don't you know i can't tell you
exactly what's going to happen next but
i certainly know the things that we are
trying to do and that we are working on
um and you can go to our website and see
all kinds of uh projects that we're
working on
in the um
in the areas of of of uh trying to lay a
better foundation for understanding
basal cognition and uh understanding
morphogenesis and developing
applications and birth birth defects and
regeneration and cancer
we're doing some work in machine
learning and trying to sort of close
that loop and understand how
we can use the principles that we learn
in biology to make better
cognitive to make novel and better
cognitive systems that are going to help
us in in various ways